All right.
Welcome back to Computer Vision.
Last time, we introduced principal
component analysis as a way of doing
dimensionality reduction,
going from a high space to a low space.
And we said it only works
if the signal actually is
present in that lower dimensional space.
In particular,
you can only reconstruct an image well
using a small number of low dimensional.
A low dimensional small
number of basis images or
eigenvectors if the image itself
was kind of like that, right?
I can only make faces out of eigenfaces,
I can't make bicycles or tortilla chips.
So that gave us a little insight, as you
might use that to do detection, right?
So if I want to find a face, I might
look for patches that can be well
described, reconstructed,
using just that low dimension.
So, there's a related task that
we can use this method for.
And that's what's called appearance
based tracking all right?
So here's the basic idea,
learn something about
what a target looks like.
Maybe not just a single image but
the possible variations
by capturing a low-dimensional space,
being able to reconstruct.
And then you're going to
track that target around
by finding the place that you can
reconstruct the best, all right?
So that's the basic idea and
what's cool about this is instead of
like some of the previous tracking.
Where if you learn new appearance
every time step, you might drift
that is you eventually get stuck on
something that's not the object.
Here you might be more robust to that.